hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a french horror thriller film
called evolution
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
nicholas is a sickly young boy living by
the sea with his mother
one day while swimming in the sea
nicholas glimpses what appears to be a
dead boy with a red starfish on his
belly
nicholas quickly picks his way across
the striking dark rocks of his town's
shoreline to report his discovery to his
mother
mom immediately goes diving and brings
back the starfish but she tells him
there is no dead body there
at home nicholas is given slimy meals
for supper and his mother gives him a
dose of medication
nicholas asks his mother what sickness
he is having his mother explains that
all boys on this island require
treatments because their bodies will
change and weaken as they get older
later that night all mothers on the
island are seen gathering somewhere
they are going to the shoreline then
nicholas mother brings back the dead
body nicholas saw before
and the other mothers gather around it
the following day
nicholas plays with his starfish after
another boy mocks him for being afraid
of it he grows angry and attacks the boy
he later hacks off one of the starfish's
arms after his outburst
his mother takes him to a hospital for
regular observation
at the hospital a doctor injects a
yellow liquid into nicola's stomach
he is then told to stay one night in the
hospital nicholas later finds himself in
a ward with other boys who have been
similarly
operated on they begin to question what
sickness they are having
at night the scene shows nurses who are
watching videos of cesarean sections
being performed
the following day nicholas is released
from the hospital
he begins to suspect his mother and the
nurses of having lied to him
he visits his friend's house victor and
they sneak out in the middle of the
night to observe what the mothers are
doing
however on their way victor gets scared
so he runs back home
nicholas continues his way in order to
discover the truth
when he arrives he's very surprised at
what he sees
he sees the women lying together
completely nude riding around in the mud
and passing an object from one to
another he immediately runs back home
a few hours later at home he sneaks a
peek at his mother as she is showering
off the mud
he observes that she has what appears to
be suckers on her back
back at the hospital nicholas is given
an ultrasound
to his mother's apparent joy they hear
the heartbeat of a fetus
nicholas is then taken into a room to
stay another night in the hospital while
waiting for the final surgery
in that room he meets other children
including his best friend
victor later that night victor is
operated on
after the operation a creature is taken
out of his stomach and put in a jar
victor dies during the operation in the
morning
nicholas asks the nurse about victor's
whereabouts the nurse lies
and tells nicholas that victor is
recovering a nurse brings a conch shell
into the ward saying that victor has
sent it to them
nicholas's mother visits him and she
brings food for him
however he refuses to eat what she feeds
him
when she becomes upset and begins to
look through his sketchbook he accuses
her of not being his mother
they then sedate him and take away his
drawing book in the hospital
nicholas develops a friendship with one
of the nurses stella
who seems to have taken a liking to
nicholas stella sneaks nicholas crayons
and draws with him
nicholas drawings include a dead boy and
starfish but also a bicycle
a car a building and a giraffe stella
then tells him a secret
she shows nicholas a file with pictures
of women with suckers on their backs
including one of a young girl that night
she takes him down to the sea shows him
the suckers on her back
and allows him to touch them before
taking him into the water
however due to being in the water for
too long nicholas passes out
stella immediately revives him using cpr
nicholas goes back to the hospital at
night he sneaks into another room
where he finds one of the boys when
nicholas approaches
the boy lays nicholas hand on his own
stomach and he feels movement in the
boy's body
after forcing nicholas to press on his
stomach he begins to vomit
nicholas runs away in fear and enters a
different room
in that room he sees one of the boys
floating in a tank
not long after he is caught by a nurse
and he is taken for the final surgery
after the surgery nicholas awakens in a
tank he is in restraints and sees what
appears to be two babies inside the tank
with him
he is shocked to see this and he faints
nicholas wakes up and again finds
himself by the sea with stella
they again enter the water but this time
she presses her mouth to his as she
swims with him
giving him air to breathe underwater she
pushes him to the surface
and the two end up in a small rowboat
floating away from the island
after making sure nicholas has a drink
of fresh water stella slips back into
the sea
presumably to go back to the island
nicholas stays on the boat and
by nightfall finds himself approaching
the harbor of a major city
and that's the ending of the movie now
for the explanation
the story is happening in a place by the
sea where we see a group of humanoids
living their lives
this place as you can see is only young
boys and female adults
no young girls or male adults as shown
later in the movie
the female adults have suckers on their
backs indicating that they are humanoid
water-based life forms they breathe
underwater too
these humanoids are the result of the
evolution of the starfish
the only way this species can reproduce
is asexual as there are no adult men
it looks like the only way to make
babies is by externally creating a
zygote and placing them in the bellies
of young boys
the bodies of these boys seem to be able
to host the fetus up until one point
after that the fetuses need to be
surgically removed and grown externally
sometimes if the boy's body is able to
survive they place the boy in a tank
where the fetus grows externally in the
water while still connected to the boy
as we can see in the movie nicholas is
being given medication every day
this is to prepare his body to host the
fetus when it is time
he's admitted and the zygote is injected
into him
other boys on the island are being given
the same treatment we can assume that
all those young boys are stolen
continuously from cities and taken to
the seaside place
in the movie we can see nicholas draws
not only a dead boy and starfishes
but also a bicycle a car a building and
a giraffe
nicholas is drawing these from memory as
they cannot be found in the village
this suggests that he was kidnapped as a
baby and brought there
however the boys grow remembering very
little where they came from
at the beginning of the film nicholas
saw a dead body
we can assume that he died while trying
to escape and those women chose to keep
it a secret
in the film we also see the women lying
together riding around in the mud
and passing an object from one to
another this is a kind of birth
reproduction ritual
having a baby among them drives those
women into a maternal frenzy and they
produce zygotes which is then gathered
and injected into boys to impregnate
them
in another scene we're shown a glimpse
of the humanoids watching a video of a
cesarean operation
this is how they have been figuring how
to cut the abdomens without hurting the
fetuses
it appears that the humanoids usually
get the cesarean cut wrong and end up
killing the host kid
we can see this happens to victor who
dies after the operation
however sometimes they are able to cut
just right and transfer the host into
the incubation tank
this happens to nicholas who survives
the operation
once inside the fetuses grow pretty
quick and the host stays alive
perhaps to be implanted with another
zygote afterward at the end of the movie
stella who genuinely loves nicholas
decides to save him from his misery
she then sneaks nicholas out and takes
him to a boat this appears to be the way
the humanoids travel and enter into
human cities to abduct kids
as it becomes night nicholas sees that
he's approaching the shore of a human
city
we can assume that he will be rescued
and unite with his original parents
and that's my explanation for the movie
subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for